what's driving me craziest i guess of
watching these images
is finding out how good the taliban is
at trolling
the taliban they've been around for a
long time they're these arch islamic
fundamentalists but apparently they're
really internet savvy they're really
good at trolling now it's really awful
to see this as an american they just
posted a photo
of them wearing american military
equipment very expensive nice american
military equipment hoisting the taliban
flag
recreating the image from iwo jima
and they know exactly what they're doing
and they're posting it now
all over
all over the internet they po they've
been posting memes you know there's a
meme it's the chad meme of
it's hard to explain a meme on air but
it's of you know sort of wimpy liberal
guys you know complaining about
something that they're doing and then
the sort of chad strong tough guy saying
yes and then it and it's and it's got
all of these various internet characters
so either they've got a great pr
consultant or some members of the
taliban actually are following american
pop culture pretty closely you remember
the the press conference they gave it
was one of the greatest trolling
performances i've seen in my lifetime
you've got these these warlords from
this backwater this godforsaken land and
they come up with their
their
theological theocratic views that have
not changed even in the slightest for
about 1400 years and they're sitting
there ask being asked about free speech
and they say oh well maybe you should
ask the west about facebook because they
doesn't seem like the west cares much
about free speech
they're asked about the role of women in
their government they said oh don't
worry we'll be very inclusive
we'll be very diverse and inclusive
within the boundaries of sharia law
which is to say obviously not at all are
they going to model their government
after the west
but they know the language of the west
they know the idiosyncrasies of the west
they know how the west is going to react
going back to the very beginning of the
afghanistan war
they said the west has the watches
but the taliban's got the time
right we're just going to wait you out
we know that you're not going to want to
stay here for 100 years no one wants to
stay in afghanistan for 100 years so
you're going to get tired your
democratic politics is going to pull you
out of the country and then we'll come
right back in
and there and they're laughing at us
doing it they're they're not only
winning all of these battles they're
laughing at us while they do it why
i think the reason here
is that the taliban has a substantive
vision
for society i i don't think it's a
particularly great vision i think it's a
perverse vision but it has substance
they
in the taliban in this militant group
of ragtag people who i guess they're not
so ragtag now because they have all our
military equipment
they know what they want society to look
like and they have cohesion among their
group they've got buy-in on what what
they all want society to look like
we in the west
do not
we don't have a substantive vision
certainly on the right we don't and we
don't have cohesion
okay all we do is sort of criticize or
we
we deconstruct things on the left and we
debunk things on the right and we all
we're all engaging in critical thinking
or the the prevailing analytical lenses
are critical theory or a critical race
theory it's all about tearing things
down
the west in part failed in afghanistan
because we didn't know what we wanted to
do did we want to just kill osama bin
laden do we want to just kill some
terrorists do we want to nation build
did we want to hoist the pride flag did
we want to instill
1970s feminism in what what are we doing
do we want to stop china do we want to
stop russia is it there to check their
ambitions do we want an empire do we
want to just be a nation what are we
doing
the taliban knows what it's doing
if we want to effectively
offer a different an alternative for
society we need to know what that is we
need to know what we're doing
to give you an example
of just how unserious we are in this
country
you you before you go
hold on slow down
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in let's just hear me
out type in
the michael knowles show
hit search
it comes up they're probably going to
bury the results but it'll you know
it'll come up eventually subscribe
leave a five star review maybe leave a
comment here on youtube before you leave
i would appreciate it greatly it'll help
us get around some of the big tech stuff
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you